MARK MIRCHANDANI: The Google
Cloud Talent Solution Job
Search API uses machine
learning to determine
the relevance of job listings
when a user searches for jobs.
Let's talk a bit more about what
determines search relevance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you haven't seen the
previous videos in this series,
I definitely recommend
checking them out.
Jobs in companies have
quite a few properties
that the machine
learning models reference
to determine the relevance
of search results.
You can influence that
relevance significantly
by providing more
information, or using things
like custom ranking
and featured jobs.
Of course, search
result relevance
can be complex to
measure, especially
since different things are
relevant to different people.
The job search API
uses an algorithm
based on a few signals
from the job data.
One of the most
important properties
is geographic location.
Both companies and jobs
have location properties,
but the job location will be
used over the company location
when a user does a search.
You should be using
the specific address
fields for jobs and
companies so that the API can
geolocate it and use
it to return the most
relevant jobs for a search.
If someone searches
for San Francisco,
they probably want to see jobs
in and around San Francisco
first and foremost.
The next determination
is how fresh a job is.
Basically, newer jobs
are ranked higher
than updated or older jobs.
Like all of these
signals, it's used
in combination with the
data to make sure the search
results are relevant.
So a newer job that's
completely unrelated
shouldn't show up at the
top just because it's new.
The title and
description of a job
play a major role in determining
if it's right for a search
query, of course.
If a job for a scrum
master is posted
and the description mentions
managing software developers,
then a search for "software
development manager"
should include that job.
Make sure to avoid just
stuffing a bunch of keywords
into a job description,
or you may end up
with some less relevant
jobs being surfaced.
The API also has some
parameters that you
can pass when doing a search
to better control the results.
Keyword match lets
you enable or disable
if the search should look for
keywords beyond the regular ML
driven search results.
Broadening will widen the search
scope for the given parameters,
allowing you to get more
results for a search.
Diversification
level lets you choose
if similar jobs should appear
near each other in search
results, or if it should only
display the most relevant one.
Check out the earlier
Best Practices video
to see some more
details on these.
There's also a lot of
features of the API
to consider when searching,
such as any filters of type
like employment, or
distance from a location.
Using the commute
search options lets
you filter by how
long it would take
to travel to and from the job.
Using featured jobs lets
you promote individual jobs.
So they could appear in
their own promoted section.
You can even enable
custom ranking
to manually influence
search results based
on your different custom fields.
With all of these
factors in play,
the API has a lot
of considerations
when determining which jobs
are most relevant to a search.
Your business logic may also
dictate certain requirements,
which you can achieve through
the search parameters and API
features.
In addition, the ML
models will tune over time
if you've hooked up
the API events as users
interact with your job search.
So if you're seeing results that
are unexpected or surprising
when doing a search,
here's a quick checklist
to help investigate
what might be happening.
First up, if a job isn't showing
up when you think it should be,
make sure to check the details.
With all the factors
we just mentioned,
it's important to double
check the title, description,
location, and any of the filters
that may be on the search that
might exclude it.
Also, check to see that
the job hasn't expired yet
since expired jobs won't
return in the results.
If the search request has
diversification level enabled,
the job you're
looking for may have
been moved to the
end of the list,
because a more relevant
and very similar
job was displayed first.
On the other hand, if a job
is showing up in results
that it shouldn't
be, you should still
start to check with
the job details.
When checking for
details, make sure
to look at the
location for the job,
and if the search request
may include a location,
since that may push this
job higher up in relevance.
Additionally, check to see if
the search request has enabled
broadening turned
on, which will relax
some of the stricter job search
conditions to return more jobs.
If a job is showing up
lower in the search results
than you would expect,
you'll definitely
want to check everything
on the search request.
Custom ranking, feature
jobs, keyword matching,
and diversification
level can all heavily
affect the order in
which jobs show up.
You should also look at
the location of the search
and at the more relevant jobs to
see if they more closely align.
Also, don't forget to check the
freshness of the job posting
to see if the more relevant
jobs are also more recent.
If the locations for
a job are showing up
incorrectly or in
unexpected places,
check the derived location
information for a job.
The information provided for the
job location may have targeted
the job somewhere
else than intended,
or the job may be
inheriting its location
from the parent company.
Make sure you're
using the Addresses
field with a full address
rather than putting
the address in the
description or putting
something not specific
enough, like just California.
If a job isn't returning
for some searches that
use industry-specific
terms, it's
most likely that those
terms aren't recognized
by the Job Search API.
If you've hooked
up events handling,
the ML models will train
themselves over time
to better match searches
for those words.
In addition, you can
use custom fields
to include synonyms
and other search
values to help more jobs show up
when an industry term is used.
These are some
steps you can check
as you integrate and debug
the implementation of the API.
If you're still not
sure what's going on,
make sure to grab the request ID
from your search request, which
is returned with
every API request.
That ID has all the
information for the search,
and you can provide
it to the support team
so that they can help
figure out what's going on
if you file a support request.
As you can see, there's a lot
of power in the Job Search API.
If you haven't
already, check out
our previous videos and the
documentation for a deeper
dive on these subjects.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, when
looking for talent,
it's OK to keep your
head in the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]